welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and iron man was
a genius who took all kinds of secrets
to the grave with him
secrets that are now being revealed from
a new marvel in universe book the
wakanda files
in which shuri journals a ton of tech
related details from the infinity saga
including tony stark's private notes a
reminder to all of us before you head
into a fight with thanos clear that
search history but there is an easy to
miss detail from this book when it comes
to tony stark's relationship with the
infinity stones
that i think answers a huge question
that was never
really explained an answer that i
believe sheds light not only on tony
stark's actions in endgame infinity war
and age of ultron but his possible
foresight of an even
more chaotic shitstorm ahead in one
division
okay so the iron man moment that has
always stood out to me and too many of
you based on how often i get asked about
this
was stark's confrontation with thanos
and infinity war stuck
you know me i do
you're not the only one cursed with
knowledge
my only curse is you this little
exchange blew so many minds
how did thanos know who stark was and
what did he mean by
cursed with knowledge well the
filmmakers did shed
some light on this in the director's
commentary joe russo explained that
thanos news starts in the battle of new
york as the avenger who threw a nuke at
his fleet through the wormhole russo
went on to describe a sort of
existential connection between thanos
and tony
screenwriter christopher marcus added
that there's a parallel between thanos
and tony in that they're both aware of
something from an early point
and constantly having to deal with being
smarter thanos is a futurist as much as
tony stark
so that has been our best explanation
for what thanos meant by
cursed with knowledge thanos sees a
common futurist mindset between the two
of them a mindset that drives both of
them into obsessive insanity but in this
explanation what do they mean by
existential connection what do they mean
by an
early point what did they mean by each
of those spaces between the words well
now this wakandaphiles book just gave an
even deeper insight into that insanity
and a very specific
answer to what curse by knowledge could
really mean see one section includes
stark's notes from age of ultron in
which he described using the mind stone
to create a supercharged jarvis aka
vision and then tony writes something
interesting he says
hold up i'm really burying the lead here
thor mentioned
six infinity stones at the center of a
whirlpool that was the destruction of
earth
and one of them is apparently bedazzling
the forehead of vision can we talk about
that for a second
infinity stones so yeah tony's referring
to thor's weird bath
in age of ultron in which the gold of
thunder foresaw the infinity stones
so this means tony already knew about
the infinity stones from thor
meaning that when strange and wong
lectured him about the stone history
three years later it wasn't really new
information to him
by the dawn of the universe there was
nothing
then big banks and six
elemental crystals hurtling across the
virgin universe
these infinity stones each control an
essential aspect of existence
tell me his name again yeah no [ __ ] tony
was like yeah baby
about these rainbow bath rocks thor
already told me about tell me more about
that thick boy who wants him
and we now know that the curse tony
shares with that
thick boy wasn't just a general futurist
perspective but
a specific mental disorder that stemmed
from the same
source which tony brings up twice in
this new book passage
the mind stone look being left in
mystery can be a good thing for example
not knowing for sure whether someone's
carrying the most discreet front pocket
wallet
the ridge thanks to the ridge for
sponsoring this episode so the ridge
helps you carry what you need every day
from their flagship ridge wallet to
their portable charging commuter
backpack they want to make the most out
of what you're bringing with you the
ridge wallet is made out of
military-grade materials like titanium
or carbon fiber
it has a clean stylish design and it's
chainsaw proof so you can go ahead and
pick that fight with a local lumberjack
your cash and cards will be safe
this is their matt cobalt wallet they
have other colors including some very
flashy tiki designs
it's light it's strong and it's blue the
color of her eyes
they make it easy to buy with free
shipping and free returns in a lifetime
guarantee and it's got thirty thousand
five star reviews so you know they're
doing something right they also have
great backpacks and travel bags with
rfid blocking pockets and optional
device charging batteries
get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com
new rockstars that's ridge.com new
rockstars and use the code
newrockstars find the link in the
video's description so why
is the mind stone so important to tony
and thanos being cursed by knowledge
well we learned in age of ultron that
the mind stone carries a sort of
cosmic intelligence you have to guess
what's it look like it's like it's
thinking
i mean this could be it's not a human
mind
i mean look at this you're like neurons
firing
in an infinity war vision again
describes this mind stone
divine ai this
is it the stone again it's as if it's
speaking to me
what does it say adam
i don't know but something
vision and wanda were on the run here
and tony said vision turned off his
transponder two weeks prior
presumably right when these mine stone
migraines began
but tony drops something interesting
about vision when he reports that to
banner honey you lost another superbot i
didn't lose him he's more than that he's
evolving
evolving yeah tony was very aware
of exactly what the mind stone was doing
division
and these wereconophiles bring up the
mindstone twice it was
very much on tony's mind because if you
think about it tony's whole futurist
knowledge curse
began with the mind stone the moment he
grabbed loki's scepter in sokovia
and the moment scarlet witch cursed his
mind with that apocalyptic nightmare
wanda's sorcery was activated by the
mind stone
something that another passage in these
wakanda files made very clear
so stark's curse came directly from that
dark wisdom contained within that yellow
stone and here's where tony's
parallelism with thanos is so important
because thanos also had early possession
of that mind stone
and no one ever talks about it thanos
sent loki to earth for the space stone
and to do that
thanos gave loki the scepter which is
powered with the mind stone that means
thanos had the mind stone before the
others that makes it
fittingly ironic that the last of the
six stones he gathers in infinity war
is that same mind stone the final piece
of thanos puzzle
allowing him to link his mind with all
the other beings in the universe in the
same way tony stark was haunted by
whispers of the mind stone to see a
future apocalypse that he
somehow survives to become a farmer a
future that he can later fix by giving
his life this same
is true for thanos who also once held
the mind stone survives an apocalypse
becomes a farmer and fixes his desired
future by
giving his life that is exactly why when
2014 thanos sees that sacrifice in the
future he isn't all that
surprised
and that is destiny fulfilled isn't it
interesting how of
all the infinity stones the one that is
coming back immediately
in marvel's first phase four story is
the mind stone still bedazzling vision's
forehead
in one division could it be that tony
stark and thanos's curse
didn't just foretell the doom the mind
stone would wreak alongside the other
five stones infinity war end game but
the even worse madness this stone
isolated could
unleash when the witch it birthed under
the influence of demonic entities
uses it to shred the universe into
pieces
exactly what thanos promised he would do
i will
shred this universe down to its last
adam
the two futurists weren't just cursed
with a vision of doom and end game
they were cursed with a vision of wanda
in one division
shattering the universe into a
multiverse of madness something the mind
stone
could enable her to do within that
pocket reality wanda even merely usurps
thanos as the universe's most powerful
being when they fight
you took everything from me
i don't even know who you are you will
a pretty prophetic assurance that
matches a similar
tone given by tony moments earlier
tony stark was cursed with knowledge
knowledge given to him
by the mind stone the same stone that
also inspired a younger thanos
putting both of these futurists on a
collision course that
neither of them will survive but one
thing will survive the mind stone
and the curse lives on oh and uh by the
way i am wearing the latest obsession
shirt from our new official merch store
which you can now get along with a bunch
of other great designs like a hi i'm
eric loss shirt
at newrockstarsmerch.com check that out
also be sure to subscribe to rockstars
here on youtube hit that notification
bell follow me on instagram at eavos
follow new rockstars thanks for watching
and wong take us out
[Music]
you